many of you may be new to this channel
and for those who are unacquainted my
name is kurt jaimungal
i'm a filmmaker making a documentary
called better left unsaid which is all
about
when does the left go too far the link
to the trailer to that is in the
description
now this channel started as unedited
interviews for that documentary but then
expanded to include my primary interests
of mathematical physics
consciousness free will theories of
everything
and god it's because of this latter
topic that i was fortunate enough to
speak to tammy peterson
whose story you're likely familiar with
but regardless if you're not we go
through it anyway the short of it is
that she was terminally ill and then
made a miraculous recovery
i don't use that term lightly it's just
that i don't know
what other word to use improbable would
be the closest but that doesn't seem to
convey the sheer unlikeliness
thank you to her husband who graciously
allowed the filming of this to take
place
in his office even though he was busily
preparing for the launch of his next
book
beyond order which is coming out in just
a few days and is available at virtually
all book retailers
we touch on several topics including the
difference between truth and love
finding god in suffering living for
what's outside you
external values versus inner motivations
and how to discover
personal blame within conflicts in a
relationship
tammy peterson is a benign woman who
to paraphrase larry david should have a
job
talking people down from ledges because
of how calming her voice is
and how ironic her message is i hope you
enjoy it even a fraction as much as i
did
it's good to see you thank you it's very
bright in this office this is the first
time i've sat in here
yeah it's different to see someone
else's face in that seat
yes i imagine that's for sure well i
don't sit here very often not now that
he's home
do you have any questions for me before
we start i read about you some
you know whatever was online and i
watched your interview with eric
weinstein
and uh um
professor viveki oh right right right
yeah i was more of a whippersnapper back
then how long ago were those improved
how long those were almost a year ago so
verviki was a year and a half do you
have you ever met vervice yeah i know
him yeah
oh great great yeah i like him he's a
cool guy yes he's a very cool guy
and eric i just met virtually but yeah
yeah i've met
him too yeah yeah so i know them both i
saw
i listened to eric weinstein play play
the fiddle on stage before one of
jordan's
lectures oh yeah i didn't know that yeah
yep yep he's a man of many talents he is
tammy why don't you tell me a little bit
about what your average day looks like
what time do you
wake up generally do you have a routine
do you meditate do you eat a certain
type of meal do you do yoga so on and so
on
i have quite a structured morning
my afternoons aren't as structured my
evenings are pretty structured
because i share them with my husband and
he's very structured in his evening
so my morning starts out um i get up
i eat random time between seven and
eight in the morning
and uh i just wake up when i wake up
before my alarm
if i don't wake up before my alarm i
know i'm tired so
i just let myself sleep but uh as soon
as i wake up
i um i pray
just re immediately i pray and i ask for
god's will as soon as i wake up
uh i try if i have any um
ruminating thoughts or
anything on my mind that is
an obsessive thought of any sort i just
say that i will be done until it goes
away
and then i get up i get up and i shower
and then i take my rosary to the front
porch and it's really bright out there
because it faces south
and it's all it's a porch that's all
closed in with um
stained glass so it's a really pretty
place to sit and the sun comes in there
really nice it's east and south so you
get the morning sun
and the afternoon sun which is very
important to me it's always been
important to me i grew up on the prairie
where there was lots of sunshine
and uh i was very interested in
when i come home from school at noon i'd
always lay in the sun
i was quite a cat i just loved to be in
the sun and i i felt
the sun was important to me it was
healing somewhere it was calming some
way it was good
and so i still feel that way in fact
when we bought this house
it was quite a dark house uh hadn't been
renovated since 1935 so the wallpaper
was hanging in ribbons off the
walls when we walked in and it was
vacant uh the family that had lived
there moved in in 1925
and his parents had died and he'd stayed
there and
become senile and the neighbors put him
in
a home and the house was sold and we
bought it
some of the neighbors who lived around
were just renting their houses because
they didn't want to live beside him
because
of the strange behavior that he had
later in his life kind of spooked people
so we moved into this house
that had spooked people quite a bit and
so that that was interesting and i shied
away from it but
i was convinced to move in and so we
renovated it and i worked as the
contractor
and put it like dug it down to the
basement and went back to the brick
and rebuilt the whole thing in six
months and we moved in
so this house has been transformed
a number of times and and we're still
here we eventually put longhouse on the
third floor so now
it's our house like who's gonna buy a
house with a long house on the third
floor so it's house
it's our house whether we live here or
not so i go out to the front porch
which is a glorious place to be and i
pray the rosary
every day it only takes about 15 minutes
so it's not a
ridiculous undertaking to give yourself
15 minutes in the morning to um
to focus your thoughts on god and you
know every every rosary day every day of
the rosary there's a different story
that goes from you know conception to
crucifixion
and then there are five
you know there's ten beads so there's
five stories that
that that make up each day and with each
story there's a
a moral i guess and so you can
you can do whatever you want with the
rosary but i i pray on the morals
so i pray on faith or i pray on hope or
i pray on
obedience or i pray on prudence you know
i pray on those things so
i go through and sometime and i usually
give a prayer for my dad he's
90 years old so i give a prayer for my
dad he asks me to will you pray for me
tom i say yeah i'll pray for you dad
and uh i pray for my husband and i pray
for the world
in and its challenges
and so then i do that and um then i
meditate
um i have a group that meditates for 15
minutes
in the morning and so that's really good
and
what kind of meditation mindful
meditation
just so i sit and i breathe and i focus
on what i want to focus on
um it depends what i'm
concentrating on sometimes i have a
problem and
i'll spend some of the time on that
problem otherwise i'll just breathe
and let god in as much as i can what you
mean is you'll clear your mind to just
focus on that one problem in a calmer
state
yes while breathing well i've done yoga
since i was 13 years old that's when i
began my
i had an aunt who introduced me to hatha
yoga when i was visiting in the summer
for a couple of weeks and she gave me a
book
and i took it home and started doing
yoga every day
and so i've done yoga
most days since i was 13 years old
and that was very helpful because you
know during your high school years
they're very chaotic at least mine were
and i'd come home at night and do yoga
and it would bring me back to
myself and i could
reflect on where i was in my life and
often it wasn't
you know a very structured place i was a
teenager
so i was out with all the other kids
doing wild things and i'd come home and
think well that i'm in kind of a wild
place
that's not easy to go to sleep that way
and
so a wild place mentally yeah because i
think when you go out and you
carouse with other people you're
definitely going to be in a wild place
mentally too
you know an unstructured place
an unknown place really because in when
you're a teenager it's uh
difficult to run your own show so you're
looking for
you might be looking for excitement you
might be looking for
um belonging you know there's lots of
things that teenagers are looking for
and so they get pulled this way in that
way by whoever they're with
was there something that you were
looking for you you me
oh probably teenagers in general look
for yeah i think there was something i
was looking for
um i was looking for belonging for sure
i was trying to understand my
motivations you know
because you know kids they do things
like go to a party and get drunk and
then you come home and you think why did
i do that
what what drove me to do that like why
did i
why did i go there or why did i talk to
that person or why did i go home with
that person
why'd i get a ride home with him he was
drunk although my dad taught me to sit
beside the driver
and make sure i got home that was his
advice
yeah that's right yeah were you always
someone who focused on the body
yes yes definitely and my dad was a
sportsman
so he was a curler a hockey player a
baseball player a golfer
he did all of the north american sports
and he did them well he
he won lots of things and then he
umpired baseball when i was a kid
and so it sports was always there
and i like to be outside
i really like to be outside when i was a
little kid i used to dig up worms
and spend a lot of time in the garden
with with the dirt
and everything that grew outside so i
really like to get my hands in the dirt
i like to pick up
rocks and find out what was underneath
them and uh i even had a wagon and i
used to
i used to pick up earthworms and put
them in kleenexes and
tuck them into bed and pull them around
in my wake
yeah so from the time i was a little kid
i was outside playing in the mud puddles
you know just constantly outside
skipping
i was just outside always my son's first
words were outside
so he's a little bit like me wanting to
be outside that's where god is
for me is outside and so if i go for a
walk
i can i can have a
i can have a meditation with god
so i used to have a dog and when i
walked the dog
we would go and you know meditate and
walk around
and um we as in you and the dog man the
dog
yeah man the dog would meditate dog
would meditate with me he was
he was you know he was in line with me
he was a little more snappy than me he'd
snap at people i didn't
yeah my daughter said i'm very
open so i i ramble when i talk
oh no no please do please keep going i
like it it takes me to
places i didn't think it would go as for
you with the body
see for me i am
i like puzzles i like abstractions i
like what takes cognitive effort
but i'm so out of tune with my own body
so much so that if the doctor asks me
where do i feel a pain
i have a diffuse notion it's somewhere
here
i don't know if it's inside don't know
if it's i have to
sit and pay close attention for many
other people they can say well it's
precisely at the upper part of my
kneecap on the outside
for me that might take me a minute so
what
is that is first of all is that
a negative you mentioned personal
that is where god is for me outside so
then that made me think well god is
it's objective but at the same time god
is personal
so then does that mean that that's okay
if you have your own individual
proclivities curse and
and and downsides because
mm-hmm well that's just you or should i
balance myself in some way and
now pay more attention to my body well i
would say
you're you know mathematician and uh
physicist so that's what you
studied in in university i studied
kinesiology you know
right so i studied the body i i'm an
artist
i paint portraits and i sketch life
drawing
i do yoga i trained as a massage
therapist
i am i'm very much about the body
but and so i know about it so if i go to
the doctor i know
you know i can explain but i've studied
that i studied that
intensely my whole life i've studied it
so if someone asked me a question about
um anything to do with the
solar system or anything i wouldn't be
able to say anything except for
rudimentary knowledge
so i think your understanding of it is
normal sounds normal to me
that you'd be focused otherwise and i
would be focused in
and and it's possibly something about
being a woman as well because
we have so many changes that go on in
our bodies so young
that it brings us back to our body you
know at 13 all of a sudden we're paying
attention to our bodies even if we
hadn't paid attention
at all until we were 13 at 13
bang you're paying attention to your
body and you have to otherwise you make
a mess so you
you have to pay attention and also
your emotions go you know all over the
place and so then you're paying
attention to what's going on there so
i think at least for myself
i accepted that as a challenge
and and you talked about puzzles i like
puzzles but i think of life as a puzzle
and i think of putting thing pieces in
place while i get
better understanding of myself
physically emotionally and spiritually
that's my puzzle that i have worked on
if you might give me a specific example
of a situation
that you viewed as a puzzle and then how
you thought about solving it
okay well i did that today
i had a piece of a puzzle that got you
know that i understand better
so um i i'm
i have an art table downstairs and i'm
taking art classes on zoom and i'm
really having a good time
life drawing on zoom landscape drawing
on zoom
um all kinds of i have some post cancer
wellness spring offers different
programs for people who've
in them are in the middle of treatment
or who have survived
treatment or their caregivers they can
take courses through wellspring
and some of them are art therapy courses
so i take those
so all that stuff is is is really good
for me and i sit down stairs and
and do what i want but
now i can't remember your question you
have to ask it again oh oh where's the
puzzle
oh the puzzle okay so i was in a class
a life drawing class on sunday morning
and uh
my husband came down and said goodbye
and i
snapped at him i wasn't i wasn't
you know i wasn't um i wasn't kind
he'd interrupt he yesterday he
i was concentrating on something he
interrupted and i wasn't kind
in my response and so later we talked
about it
and i thought you know i think i
understand
because if i look back over the last 20
years
of having children getting married
having children having them grow up
i left my art largely behind for
a number of years and i could never
understand why
so i meditated on it this morning
and i thought back to my mother and her
father
who both had troubled
childhoods and
were pro and then i thought about their
childhoods and i thought well there
would have been fear
there would have been lack of love and
uh my mother was physically she was you
know some people you walk in the room
and the room is cold
so they're giving off something that you
know is
cold it's not a warm feeling a welcoming
generous feeling
and my mom used to have that happen
and so i would be jumping through hoops
trying to
get attention from her and to get proper
love in my direction when i was a kid
and it really wouldn't change her it was
what i wanted
wasn't necessarily what she needed or
wanted or knew about so it was just
something i was doing on my end
and so i have a tendency
but i had a good time with her if she
would color with me
so doodle art i don't know if you know
doodle art but do like they sometimes
have great mythic
uh doodle arts that you can color and my
mom used to color them with me
and you know i used to garden with her
but that was work and duty you know and
she used to sew me doll clothes when i
was a kid but she was doing the sewing
and i was doing the watching
but when we colored we colored together
so that was a shared activity
and last night i was babysitting my
granddaughter she's three
and she was getting sleepy and we went
down to my art table and
got out a coloring book and
and so she likes to use my art pencils
and so we were coloring
pocahontas and and her uh hummingbird
and raccoon that are in that story
and i was quite enjoying it and she
would color a bit and then she'd say
grandma color here and i'd color there
and then what color should that be
let's give her pink hair red hair blue
hair you know we were just
purple legs we were having a great time
and so i thought about all that when i
was meditating and i thought
well when i'm doing art
it gives me a warmth which was some of
the
only warmth i had with my mom not that
it was that drastic but you know
um my mom loved me i know she did it's
just that
there were certain times where i could
feel it more than other times and art
was one place
i really felt it and that might be why
although i have a
an aptitude for art that's also where
there's love
and warmth and so i really like to do it
and i left it for 20 years and didn't do
it
i until the art therapy until
yeah until i till i had
this brush with death and renovated my
house and gave myself a good space
to set myself up
and made it a priority and
so i made i made the act i changed the
action first
and then when
the underlying trouble that had been
stopping me
i guess maybe then it was safe enough
for it to come up
and it came up and i barked at my
husband
which showed me that i had spent 20
years
not doing what i wanted to do and blamed
him for it
in that moment or you realize that oh
i've known that before but it never
really
came up so that it was very much
in the moment for both of us to be
paying attention to it
and to and i wasn't i wasn't
uh confident enough or organized enough
to answer his question in a way that
could
calm him and make him believe that i
am addressing it and that everything
will be okay you were suggesting that
well actually first if you don't mind i
would like to know the nature
the nature of your bark because for me
when i'm working i have a tendency to do
something similar where i bark but it's
not
but sometimes it's more caustic than
other times like
most of the time it's it's babe i'm
working i'm working
but sometimes it's like i can say it
more harshly or i can say something else
i don't swear
right but i i understand that it can be
i understand it hurts her at times
yeah i just said i said you can go
okay and do you mind what did he
do before that and then what did you say
like where were you in the kitchen and
oh no i was
he came downstairs to where my art
table is into the basement that's where
i have it
and i have i cut a nice big hole in the
wall so there's
light coming in the stairs from the
upstairs are
they're not solid so the light from
outside comes in that way and i have a
back basement door with a big window in
it so there's light there's natural
light
right there in the basement i have
really good overhead lights so i can
really light
this art table that i have so that's
where my computer is and that's where
i do all my art projects and whatever
else i might be doing
so i was down there my computer was in
front of me
it was obvious that i was in a class
i was drawing and he came down and asked
he said he needs some groceries
and i thought that's not
important right now to me because i'm in
the class so i said i'm in a class
and he continued and i said
that that was you know that was enough
that he could go
and then i called him and i said you
know just send me a text
just right you can go as in you can go
get the groceries no you can just go
he's honest you can leave like the king
says
you know you know how queen elizabeth
she hits that little bell and then
whoever's talking to her has to get up
and leave
yeah that kind of thing yeah so
you know there's a lot of um that would
be pride i think or
or um a sense of entitlement for sure so
so those
those that kind of understanding so if i
get that
if i get a a clue that i'm acting in
that way
then i can address it then i can say
okay where did that come from
look back in my
whatever comes up for me when i'm
meditating and think okay well maybe
maybe i need this and i haven't been
getting it
and instead of admitting that i was
uh
blaming someone else for something i
didn't do
or i was also um
whatever else i was doing i was kind of
trying to control my environment
of things i couldn't control and can't
control but i was trying to
to get if you know when people do that
it gives them some self gratification
because they've gone off and
and tried to make everything better for
other people
but have denied themselves something
that they need
like that that's a that's a recipe for
disaster you know that's what that is
and so i think in the past
in my way of thinking that i was
thinking before
wasn't well formulated it was a
an old plan that hadn't been updated and
so
it wasn't a plan that was going to work
for me now
or for my husband i've heard that you
have this practice where you retreat
separately and find the source of the
problem being yourself
when you have a fight a conflict with
your oh i can imagine that it can be
one-sided at times
at least in the beginning where you
aren't able to come up with an
idea as to how the problem was you and
then you get together the person says
yeah the problem is miso and something
you're like yeah
the problem actually at this time was
you so uh no no
not usually like usually
well if there's a fight if so there's an
argument and you go off to your own
place then you think if there's anything
in your life that you've done that may
have brought this
argument up not neces so it's not
necessarily about actually the argument
because sometimes the argument has
nothing to do with why
like often the argument has nothing to
do with actually what's wrong
maybe you're late on on something and
you bark
at your wife when she comes in it has
nothing to do with you being
angry at your wife or that she intruded
it was that you
you have a project that you're late on
and so you have to look you have to
separate and find out if there's a cause
to this
argument that you hadn't seen before
that may have
come up right then and
shown you that there was something to
pay attention to
it's something you know an argument is
something to pay attention to
because you might learn something and
those are gifts
because the next time you won't have
that same argument it won't come up
anymore
if you can figure it out did you pray
each morning before your illness no
no i didn't but my grandmothers were
both
religious and
if i had a religious question i could
ask them
um so there was it wasn't like there was
no god for me before
and i've and i've been to church and i
and my mother died in 2007
i pray to her daily i would say
so my praying has changed since i was
ill
it's become more dogmatic
and uh yeah it's become more dogmatic
and also i have a relationship with a
personal god now that i
that has that has grown in nature so i'd
say i've always been spiritual
i'm more spiritual now i take it more
seriously now i understand it better now
um i think that it's
not an option i don't think it's an
option for people to live a life
a fulfilling life meaning
that people cannot live a fulfilling
life if they don't have god
in their life yeah i i think so uh you
know what
a spiritual relationship with uh
higher power is necessary what's the
difference between
religion and spirituality well religion
is dogma you know so the church
and and all the readings the bible
all of that that's dogma spirituality is
a
feeling that god is there with you and
that if you give him space he'll tell
you
what's right and wrong that's
spirituality
and so you could and they overlap
they can't overlap but for some people
they don't
there's an intellectual understanding of
god that's not a spiritual that's not a
personal
understanding of god and i think you
need a personal understanding of god
to really make
your move yourself forward in in
in your understanding of yourself in the
world do you mind taking people through
a timeline of your illness as well as
the course of your recovery nope i don't
mind
i'm getting used to it it's been two
years so i'm getting used to it
i had no indication that i was ill
i'd gone on a walking tour with my
sister to croatia
we walked for 10 days and it was
wonderful uh i flew home and two weeks
later i got a
fever a fever and uh
kind of a gastrointestinal flu of some
sort
and the fever went away but the
digestive
gastrointestinal trouble stayed and so i
eventually went to the doctor and he
told me maybe i had a parasite
i thought oh yeah that's i should have
thought of that
so he gave me a a test and no i didn't
have a parasite oh
okay so then he thought well then let's
do a an ultrasound of your abdomen
uh have you do a colonoscopy you know
all this stuff we'll just look
and i had an ultrasound and i could see
the screen and i saw
a shadow on my kidney and so
eventually i had a bacterial problem
that i fixed before i had surgery
but they told me i had a
renal cell carcinoma which is a very
common cancer and people often have it
and it doesn't kill you because it grows
one millimeter a year yeah really really
really slow
and so then he they said don't worry
about it you can i was traveling with my
husband
on a book tour so he they said whenever
you have time you can come in the
hospital and have that surgery
um i flew back during our book tour and
had a biopsy
and i flew back for blood i i had to fly
back a couple of times
in preparation for surgery and then
march
of 2019 i went into the hospital
and i had a partial nephrectomy
of my left kidney and i left the
hospital and for six weeks
my family members gathered around me and
i got better and by six weeks i was
walking to the waterfront and back to
the annex i was healthy and
i went to my post-op appointment with my
husband and
the doctor was nervous
and loathe to talk to us
and when he talked as he told me that i
had a year to live that they were wrong
and that i had something called a
bellini tumor
which is very rare in fact so rare that
no
that they have no data on how to treat
it because people die too quickly
and by then it was in one of my lymph
nodes
a lymph node adjacent to my kidney and
they said we have to
you have to have surgery as soon as
possible
and this was around march 2019 this was
april end of april
so then june or may 9th i had another
surgery
but before i went into surgery the night
before i went into surgery
um i meditated
my husband and i were really nervous
super nervous it's no wonder because
surgery was their
only treatment they said radiation and
chemo
they had no idea that there was no good
result except for if they got it in time
so my only chance was this surgery
and so i had done a
very interesting meditation when i was
studying to be a massage therapist
years ago when i was in my 20s where
i had a cyst on one of my ovaries
and they thought it was cancer it wasn't
but
i was working with this cool artist
massage therapist guy and he said
that he was going to take me on a
journey
and i could go see what i could find out
about this
so we did a meditation where i
breathed in white light
i breathed in white light and it turned
it ended up to be like a string of light
that wrapped around
my ovary that was spinning around it was
light it was spinning around the ovary
and i was asking what was wrong and if
and if part of me was afraid if
you know if there was trouble there that
it was okay it could come talk to me
and so i was really trying to
communicate and
about two hours after this uh i had a
pain
out the side of my rib cage quite a
real noticeable pain out the side of my
rib cage and then
we stopped and i went in for my surgery
and
what they told me was the size of a
softball
was the side of size of like a ping-pong
ball
so whatever it was and it what it was
was a dermoid cyst
which has hair and skin and teeth in it
so teeth teeth
and skin and hair it's kind of like
maybe uh
a twin or that was that was never formed
and it grew when i got pregnant so it
seemed like
the hormone change in my body when i was
pregnant
made it grow but i think it it was there
already
so it was something that was waiting to
to develop but i don't it's uh they're
quite rare
anyway i had that out i was fine
but it was an interesting experience
because i really felt like i had
touched something inside myself that was
troublesome and i had calmed it down
some in this meditation it seemed that
way so the night before my surgery i
thought let's do that again
so i got jordan to sit at my feet and
move his hands like this up the insides
of my feet
which in reflexology is your
spine your br your birth canal and so it
was very it was touching it
yeah very rhythmically up one set up my
feet and then down my feet
and i said this is going to be about a
two hour get comfortable because this is
about a two hour
meditation and so then i
settled into bring in the white light
and i decided what i would do because
i'd had a lot of letters come from
all the people that we'd met when we
traveled all over the world
and i had a lot of a lot of prayers and
a lot of
letters come to me when i was first
diagnosed with cancer
and so i lined up all those people in my
mind on a beach
i lined them up on a beach and i had
them pray and i
breathed in all their prayers i breathed
in all the prayers and i took them down
to my kidney
yeah and i first i thought with a white
light and then i thought well this is
cancer let's use a gold light
because this has got to be powerful so i
breathed in gold light
and did you exhale any black muck or
were you just breathing in
i didn't i didn't breathe out any black
muck but after two hours
of of having a conversation
with this little blackness that i found
in my
kidney it seemed like a part of me was
looking the other way and it turned away
from me it looked it was my like my
cells had turned away
and i thought
they had turned away and decided to work
against me rather than with me that's
how it felt to me
and i realized somewhere in the
meditation that cancer is much too much
for one person
that it's something that i had to give
back to the universe and then
a black kind of soot
came out spun out of me and and went up
to into the universe
where it could be better dealt with
because it was too much for me
and then we went to bed and got up in
the morning and we were calm
we were calm we went to the hospital and
i told the surgeon what had happened the
night before in my meditation he said he
took that intention
into the surgery and the surgery went
really well
everything they took out nothing was
adhered to anything else
they didn't have to do any extra cutting
they just pulled out
the rest of the kidney and all the lymph
from my left side and so
i was left with my
remaining kidney and all the lymph on
the right side
because your abdomen is just full of
lamp lymph nodes
and they don't there's they go i don't
know but they go
along the blood vessels uh
the blood vessels are attached to the
heart the lymph isn't attached to any
pump at all
the lymph is moved by your movement
right and so the lymph is really the
um you know that's the sweeping
mechanism
mechanism of the body to clean out all
the toxins and so
i lost that on my left side
but that went really well and i was
getting better
for a little while
but then i started my feet started to
swell
and then my lower legs started to swell
and so we called the hospital
and talked to the nurses on the unit
that i had stayed on
that i had my surgery on and they said
well you know you've had a very major
surgery
it's no wonder that you might have some
swelling
and they would we were like oh okay it
seems extreme but
okay and so then i went to my six-week
appointment
and uh my off my uh post dot
post looking like you were pregnant on
one side or was it a bulb
or what no it was my feet especially my
left foot
were swollen up my lower legs were
swollen up
my thighs were swollen up on one side
or both i was filling up with fluid
right i was filling up with fluid there
was a leak in my abdomen
there was a leak in the lymph nodes i
see so all of my
fluids from my body were leaking into my
abdominal cavity
and then accumulating
in my body it would be as if there's a
hole in one of the pipes in your body
and the exact pipes are where the limps
yeah except for the lymph is like a
spider web that's how small it is
very very very very impossible thing to
to work with and they had tried to close
off every
i mean they had to take it all out so
they had to close off every little
spider web
and they missed one there's a surprise
right yeah
and you know the lymph they've they've
done a lot of work
with hearts and the lymph around the
heart
and they get leaks sometimes and they
really know how to fix it
but a leak in the abdomen is something
that is
because they weren't doing radical
surgeries you know what you used to hear
oh someone's got cancer
oh it's in their lymph they're gonna die
right that's what you'd hear
when i was young anyway that's what you
would hear now they can take out the
lymph
which is radical they didn't do that
and to and to have that go well
you know i don't know what the chances
are for it to go well
anyway it didn't go well for me and i
was in the hospital
twice the first time was when they
was when i went in and my limbs were all
full of fluid
and they drained off my abdomen
they put a they put a shunt into my
abdomen and they drained
off i can't remember something like
seven liters
of fluid what would be the prognosis of
this
death as well well they didn't know what
it was until they drained it off
one of the oncologists told me he
thought i had cancer the liver
or cancer of the peritoneum in the
the uh abdominal cavity which didn't
sound good
yeah that's not pleasant to hear
especially if we didn't do a test and
he's speculating well it could be
cancer of your liver i know i've had
that i've had that happen often
i'm kind of getting used to doctors
doing that i think you do
well if you've had my history of health
problems then you get used to
doctors randomly suggesting things that
they don't
have any reason to suggest anyway
when they when they took off all this
fluid it was milky colored
which is the proper color for fluid from
the lymph
because the lymph picks up fat
and the white color of milk is is fat
so it looked like milk there was no
blood in it there was no
so it wasn't cancerous it was fluid
from my lymph system but a lot of fluid
so it was really pouring out of me um
people who are with me probably know how
much was flowing out of me but
it was it's hard for me to remember it
was just
i had a i had are you on medication or
were you just so out of it because
you didn't i think i was on medication i
was on morphine
for quite a bit of the time um
and they may have put me on morphine
when they put the bag in
to keep me comfortable because it wasn't
comfortable
okay so then it would have been it was
kind of foggy for me
to know how how much i was losing a day
but
a nurse used to come to my house once
they sent me home
she would come at noon and drain off a
liter of fluid
a day and i was still very uncomfortable
i still was you know when i
before i started draining i looked like
i was seven months pregnant
now now it was still kind of a
pregnant look but wasn't as extreme
but i wasn't giving my lymph the
rest it needed to heal because there was
so much fluid
there were doctors that speculated that
if i didn't have any fluid in my abdomen
if i drained off all the fluid that it
would dry
and then it would possibly heal because
that does happen sometimes that's an
aside where's this fluid coming from
because in a regular person when i say
regular i mean
someone doesn't have this issue yeah
there's some
there's some uniform in their
distribution of fluid
now yours is pooling and then it's
leaving so is it getting replaced
so then that means it was taken from
some other part of your body to be
placed in your abdomen
i was eating and i was getting thinner
and thinner i took a picture of myself
in one day and i thought hmm
i had no body fat left at all my my
scapulas were sticking off my back my
breasts
had lost all the all of the
everything was gone my bum was gone my
breasts were gone
my cheeks were gone they were sunken
like i was down to
90 pounds so i had lost 30 pounds
probably
and i was getting desperate
and i was also not only was i on
it turned out not only was i on morphine
but because all my bodily fluids were
running out of me i was becoming
malnourished
and so my thought processes were getting
confused
but i was at home with everybody trying
to help me but it was really hard to
know
what to do because the doctors didn't
know what to do here was this
this woman she had a hole in her lymph
in her abdomen and we can and they
couldn't find it
they looked i had so many scans of
different so at this point they're
simply draining you and you can't
continue like this for
much longer um
or did they tell you yeah i recall you
saying i don't think i could they said
you can live like this and you thought
hey that's fine i can live like this
well i could when i i got a t
when i went in for the five weeks
which was right before i finally got
better they changed
i didn't eat anymore at this point now
they put a
a picc line near my heart and they fed
me
tpn which is a nutrition that you feed
people who can't use their digestive
system anymore
and you can live like that people do
live like that for 25 years
they live like that so a lot of people
what they do is they get nutrition at
night when they're sleeping
and in the day they don't eat anything
they get all their nutrition right
straight to their heart
and so what happened if you were to eat
um well what hap what they thought with
me was if they
didn't go through the lymph system that
maybe it would get better
but it didn't and so for five weeks we
were trying to
heal it in ways that wouldn't be cutting
me open again
and we weren't able to find anything
that worked
so by the time i had been in the
hospital for five weeks
i was awake again because now i was
getting nutrition
that's when i started to pray right
that's when you started i thought you
said that you started with queenie
queenie came to give you something
that's when queenie when i was in the
hospital for the last time this five
weeks
see my my electrolytes went out of
balance and i went into emergency
because my potassium was out of whack
and then you're gonna have a heart
attack and that was gonna be the end of
me
i had lost so many body fluids that my
electrolytes were going out of whack and
that's when you have a heart attack and
die
so i was i was nearly dead but not quite
when i got into the hospital and then
they pumped me full of
fluids until i was my electrolytes
balanced
and then they gave me a tpn diet until
i had enough nutrients for my brain to
turn back on and when that happened i
had been in the hospital for three or
four days
that's when queenie came to the hospital
and she said
who is queenie to you so she came up she
came up to visit queenie stopped by our
house
a couple of years ago maybe even three
or four years ago
she was a fan of my husband's and she
wanted some
she she's uh she's a catholic she
um lives
on u of t campus she is like a dorm
dawn for
catholic girls at u of t
but she also does other things she's
very interested in family
she's very interested in schooling and
family and
things that have gone i think she
contacted us
when our prime minister
and our prime minister our premier was
kathleen wynne
i think that's when she first came to
our house because she was concerned
about the
curriculum and the things that were
happening in schools
and she was i don't know she was just
this friendly little asian woman
and she came to the
she came to the hospital and she brought
me a rosary and she said do you want to
pray
i said sure why not
let's pray so i
grabbed my i had my bag in my pool and
we'd go down in the toronto general
there's a an
atrium with it's four stories high and
it's full of plants and sunshine
a little bit like being outside so i
could go down there
you must love that i loved that that was
like life you know to me that was good
so i'd go down there and i would sit
with her for two hours
and cry and pray
okay so what gave you this idea to do
this on a regular basis did you
already know that talk therapy was
curative in a psychological or physical
sense
no no she just she just showed up and
asked me if i wanted to do it and i just
said yes
so i think she knew
because you know there's a there's a
in in catholicism there are prayer
organized prayer sessions that people
can set up or you can
you can belong to a part of the church
that's all about prayer
so i belong to a part of the church
um that's uh all about prayer
and it's about just everyday people
praying
for life that's what they do is they
pray and so
that's what i do is i pray and
so you went down with her to the toronto
general atrium
every day you talked for two dollars i
mean sorry everyday you talked enough
for two dollars
for two for two hours she didn't charge
anything nope she just came
gave me a gave me a rosary and we prayed
and then i would go back upstairs and
play cards with my family
and visit with them and i just stayed
there for five weeks
praying and then just before i went to
pennsylvania to a doctor who was
hopefully going to
heal this hole i had in my abdomen
i she she asked if i wanted a priest to
come over and bless me and i said sure
and so uh a priest that works with other
eric
father eric he works at u of t he came
over to our apartment
and he blessed me and
he gave me the uh
a novena for the ill which are nine days
of prayer
for someone who's deathly ill
and told me to meditate on gratitude
and off i went to university of
pennsylvania
with my with a lot with plenty of my
family along with me
and uh they
were supposed to be the best in the
world
and i'm sure they are they did an mri
guided
they poked little needles in me with dye
and poppy seed oil
and they said now and then the poppy
seed oil will irritate
it will irritate the system and and if
there's a
a leak somewhere it will be irritated
enough
that the body will put down um
whatever kind of um tissue is necessary
i see i see just scar it up and close it
and so they looked for the leak couldn't
find it
so sorry the poppy seed oil is for
imaging purposes the poppy seed oil is
to carry the dye
i see okay and then on the mri they can
see plumes
come out if there's a leak ah cool cool
cool
yeah cool cool cool very cool very cool
very cool so they tried to look for it
they couldn't find it
they couldn't find it that means the
poppy seed oil worked
instantly no it didn't work instantly no
they couldn't find it i was still
leaking
i was leaking it was thursday
by saturday it had kind of slowed down
the leaking
but we'd had the leaking slow down
already once before and then found out
it was just a mechanical
failure of the of the bag
apparatus that i had hooked me so uh uh
right so then so it was false positive
so no no
that so this time when it slowed down we
were going so is this
better or is this just because things
aren't
properly cared for here or like so
what's going on what's going on
and they had told me that the only way
to tell
if the lymph had healed would be to eat
some fat
so at that point i was eating food again
but no fat
a no fat diet like i had done before
they're worried that would
when irritate the lymph yep because the
lymph it works with fat
so if you don't put any fat down the
lymph isn't working
and you want to limit what the lymph is
doing if you have
but you also mentioned that the lymph
serves as a garbage collector in your
body
so no matter what it would be working
but at a much lesser rate
yeah right okay much lesser rate okay
so on saturday i thought well i might as
well eat some fat and see if this has
worked or not
because on monday they're going to open
me up and do some
more major surgery to see what they can
find
so i might as well find out if it worked
before of that
and so okay i had i don't know
i think i had eggs not just the
white but the yolk
and as far as i could tell there was no
milky looking fluid in my bag it still
looked like
urine it was just yellow
and so the next morning i was at
breakfast and an intern and a nurse came
and they said well you know i think you
better eat some fat because we have to
find out
if you still if the leak is still like
what's going on there and so i said well
i already ate some fat last night
they said oh okay well like show me
what's in the bag and i pulled it up and
it was
clear and they said
this is you know this isn't what we
expected
we're very surprised your leak seems to
have
closed up and you're better you can go
home
so then they followed me for about a
month told me just to walk
not do anything else not lift anything
or anything and
they called me often and then after a
month they said well you're discharged
you're better
so i prayed then the
novena for five days and then i was
better
why weren't you allowed to lift what
were they worried what happened
oh i think just any they didn't want to
rupture if there was a new
um
it's like a new spirit you mentioned
before that when you are
terminally ill you felt like
well i've lived a good life so it's not
that bad if i die it's okay
in many respects but then you looked at
the suffering of your family and thought
okay this matters at least it matters to
them yes no
you mentioned that in a positive light
but when i was thinking
there's plenty of people and i count
myself as a part of this group where i
used to be or i
used to be depressed and in fact i was
suicidal and
it's not it's harrowing to think that
to know that the main reason you're
staying around is
to lessen the suffering of others rather
than your own internal locus
of a desire to live but you mentioned it
in a positive way
so can you expound sure
so um i did think when i was diagnosed
that i had lived for
my my aunts died my aunts and uncles
died young and so i thought oh i guess
i'm one of them
that then i'm going to die young like
them and
and and i can
i can do that i'd always been a very
independent person
making my own decisions and getting on
with life and this was just another
decision that i was making that's how it
felt to me
that this was another decision that i
was making and that i was
tough and i could do it so that was my
plan and then i went home from the
hospital and i went to tell my children
and when i told them the prognosis they
looked so hurt that something inside me
completely changed and i realized oh no
i'm not looking at this properly
this isn't this isn't my decision
because i always wondered about people
who had gone through
many cancer treatments you know many
times going through chemotherapy and
radiation and
the the things that people go through to
stay alive why would they do that
you know i've always kind of wondered
why they would do that and
i had thought no i'm not doing that if
i'm going to die then i'm going to die
and that's that
but then i went home and i told my kids
and i thought
they look so hurt
and my husband too but it was really
looking at my kids they look
so hurt that it's not my
decision so i'm going to do whatever i
can to stay
to stay alive it's
i realized that's being alive is uh
the focus is about service
it's not it's about what you can do for
others
and that's the christian story
that's an unselfish concern for the
welfare of people who aren't you
yes you know that's that's christ's
story
it's his suffering and his
sacrifice you know it's his sacrifice
that we
live by and aspire to
and so i decided that i would
be grateful for every day i had
that i would be grateful for any answers
that came my way
but i would also be
grateful for the life i've had
and so i decided that that was the only
way i could go forward
and be
and be able to accept it can you tell me
the month and the year that you
were first diagnosed and that you made
that change
from when i was not caring you mean for
for the uh
when did you make the when did you make
the change to realizing that
this is i'm looking at this incorrectly
in your
words okay so i had
uh i had got the prognosis
on i think april 26th so it was right
right around then that's when i changed
my mind do you see this as
as a gift from god or do you
like for example some people like your
husband suggest that we have to go
through hell before
some elevation so do you see it as a
gift or do you see it as
as a as the opposite like a like it's
from satan or it's a test maybe
and if it's a gift you said yes so how
is it a gift it's a gift but it's also a
test
you know because it's you know um i i
think that
i i kind of think that we're given
challenges in our life
to you know to better ourselves and to
be better people
we're given challenges this was a
challenge i was given
and i didn't quite look at it in a way
that was going to be
um i gave up
at first before i realized that it was a
challenge
that i could that i had a way
to address it i had a way to address
this challenge that i wasn't
aware of when i first heard the news i
think i was probably in shock but
still i don't think i was aware that
i had to change my attitude and
that that would be the way forward
that it would be much less painful
if i was to take it on as a challenge
and also accept it for
however it went much less painful for
who
for me and probably for everybody else
yeah i imagine for everyone else for
sure
what i'm wondering is and for me yeah
because you said
look i'm tough i can die right now
because
in some ways i can face that door and
jump off that cliff courageously
face it head-on yeah now what i'm
wondering
is you also said seemingly unrelated
that you had this fight with your
husband
some small bicker yeah and and you
retreated this was in the
kintore college video that you retreated
for whatever reason
i don't remember what it was but let's
imagine at the time you thought while
i'm retreating
because i'm tough but then you realize
through some self-analysis i'm
retreating because i'm hurt from my
childhood
i'm just making this up this last part
okay so then
did you realize did you come to some
realization about
when you said to yourself well i'm tough
so i can face death
that that wasn't actually courage it was
masking some other
hurt and that the proper path was to
face it head-on in terms of living
yeah i think so i think that my idea of
being independent
and tough was something that i've
learned to do as a coping mechanism
as a coping mechanism for
[Music]
for fear for
insufficiency you know to
to gather all my strength
and have self-will take me through
things
i realized that that's well i was up
against something bigger than that
so self-will wasn't gonna do it
i needed uh human aid wasn't wasn't
going to do it
i needed i needed uh spiritual aid
what was i'm asking exactly it was
masking what hurt or
um was it masking oh i don't know
because i think it's something i learned
from the time i was young to be
independent and to be courageous
in the face of uh in the face of a
challenge
you know and and that can you know that
can take you a long ways
it really can but when you're faced with
your own mortality it isn't enough
and so then i realized it's not enough
and in fact it's sufficient in my
day-to-day life as well
and i didn't know that before just how
true that was i didn't know it
but now i understand it better this
practice of gratitude you carry it with
you so that it's a daily habit or
yeah yeah that's the that's the goal
what sorts of i don't know if you did it
today like you just sit and you think
what am i grateful for but if you did or
if you did it recently what sorts of
items go on that list
so i have a gratitude list that
sometimes i share with others on
whatsapp there's a gratitude list
whatsapp group
and uh you belong to quite a few groups
yeah i belong to lots of groups
well that's interesting because you were
independent the group is the opposite of
that and then you've you've
come to realize the salutary nature in
the group
as well as obviously you knew it before
so what's health giving about the
independence that's super interesting
stupid oh and i and when i was dying
or thought i was dying i talked to god
and i said
god if you let me live i'll share and so
that's why i'm here
i recall you saying that i would have
said no otherwise
well first of all thank you so much oh
you're very welcome
thank you for inviting me yeah i have i
recall you saying that you spoke to some
koreans over zoom at least that was in
the kintore video you said
i spoke to them they made a joke like it
was over zoom and not i didn't go or
maybe
maybe yeah okay okay i think have you
has it just been somewhat informal just
i just was invited
just invited to speak that time it was
just 10 minutes
that i was invited to speak for and
at kintore i'm going to speak there over
zoom again
on the 27th they're having a conference
and i'm going to speak
with them i think jordan's going to
tweet out the
invitation and i'm going to speak out
about loss and
and resilience again how's the pandemic
affected you
well i'm not exactly an extrovert you
know i'm kind of in
the middle i like i i like people but i
can also do without them
so i think it's actually been
it's been okay for me um and i'm i'm
quite fortunate my son lives at the end
of the street and we're in a bubble
and he had a baby and so i've been able
to know that i recall you saying that
yeah that's cute i'm i'd i'm i'm just so
fortunate i think so in terms of
everybody else who's suffering i feel
very fortunate
so and i really like zoom i really like
it's very
handy i don't have to drive anywhere and
i can be in a meeting every hour of the
day
if i want i can learn whatever i want
it's great
to me this is almost my i know like this
is not great for people to hear but this
is almost my ideal situation because i'm
one an introvert but number two i'm a
germaphobe so i like when people
lice all their hands and don't shake
hands and oh that's funny you should say
that
i don't know if you heard me say this
but my daughter was ill when she was
young and she used to go to school and
catch things and then she'd end up with
pneumonia
so it wasn't just a little thing and i
used to be so
frustrated on an airplane when people
would cough and sneeze and
then she would get off the airplane and
she'd be sick because she just caught
everything and so in a way i've been
frustrated with this in schools
on airplanes and now thank you i think
it's a strange uh
turn of events yes it's
who would have thought one year even one
year ago it was february yeah one year
ago
we saw it coming yeah but no
well at least i didn't think it would up
end our lives for an entire year
and that this would be how it would be
with going to the stores at a certain
hour one entrance
not seeing people putting on a mask when
you leave
yeah yeah pretty strange did you think
you would find god
without your illness thinking back now
in retrospect
no not the same way no no
i wasn't gonna find him uh in a profound
way
until i had suffered more you know
different people have to suffer
different amounts before they turn to
god and i really had to
dig deep before i turned to god i find
you know i found out
i was faced with terminal diagnosis
before i turned to god
and the difference between those people
who feel the suffering
and then blame god or turn away from god
because of their suffering
rather than turn two because
um i'm not sure but i i did have a
i told you that my grandmothers were
religious
and so i had that
what from a time i was a child and i
studied yoga
and so that is also so i i had my
spirituality was always
i was always curious about it if you're
not
curious about it if you're completely in
your head and you're an intellectual
and you're doing okay then it's quite a
be quite a turnaround to have you know
you have to humble yourself
to become spiritual it's a humbling
experience there's nothing more humbling
i don't then becoming religious becoming
spiritual
you know grow god shrink tammy it's all
about
changing so that i'm down here paying
attention
i'm not up here telling god what to do
right i'm down here
that that's pretty hard so i think
people who
have a hard time uh
humbling themselves to their
higher power are going to have more
trouble
because it's it's too too hard it's
it's just some things are just too hard
to be due alone
so it'll make you angry and it'll make
you blame
i see the difference between the people
i turn toward rather than turn away
seems to be that they want to be in
control that they find it difficult to
suggest that someone else
should be in charge or that they need
help yeah yeah i think so
would you call yourself a catholic or
you don't give yourself a label at all
no i wouldn't call myself a catholic but
i definitely pray the rosary
okay you also mentioned that hey when
you were younger you went to different
religious institutions they weren't for
you and you thought perhaps religion the
dogmatic side
wasn't for you then i was thinking well
that's a common
feeling for quite a few people they
maybe try one church
two or three and then they
say this is not for me i don't like
these people or i don't like what's
being said
and then they lose this communal aspect
of religion
and you could be an independent
christian like uh like kierkegaard
but it's helpful to have a community
around you
so what would you suggest to those
people who don't who think that religion
is not for them because they've tried it
a couple times but haven't found the
right one
and they think there is no right one the
right one is me
maybe if first of all it might be just
me like i'm an atheist
or it might be just me and my personal
relationship to god and that's all
the problem is with that is you can have
a personal relationship with god or you
can have a personal relationship with a
higher power of your choosing if you're
an atheist
it doesn't matter it's just it's not you
you know it's your community or it's or
it's nature
or something is is uh inspiring you
but service is a lot of
service has is service is really what
is necessary to receive
the benefits of your
relationship with your higher power
so you have to give it away
without being thanked so it isn't
a it isn't something you're doing for
money
it isn't something that you're doing for
accolades
it's you're doing it because
you're you want to fill yourself with
god
and so the service is is what's
necessary
and when you say service this has
nothing to do with a group of people it
has nothing to do with an institution
because it has nothing to do with an
institution but it has to do with people
service service to other people to
others
to serve others yeah
helping to serve others is what is
necessary
to um have a
spiritual experience a full spiritual
experience
and you found a role model in mary i
recall you saying
now okay maybe
it wasn't a role well i didn't but
either way but i understand mary better
than i did
either way what i mean is for women
is mary more saleable than jesus
like if you're yeah speaking to women
right now and you want them to turn
toward
god or turn toward the good or turn
towards something that's
higher than them what advice do you have
well meditation is a good place to start
and trying to talk to god
you know and that's that's pretty gentle
so i would think that meditation and
trying to talk
to speak to to listen to god to listen
to god
would be a good way to start
and sharing what you learn with others
would be a good
also a good way to start because then
you'd be at least
giving other people information and
you'd be getting
information from others too about what
their experiences are
to make it more real and not diluted
see that's the problem is we're not
solitary creatures and
and if we live alone then we go crazy
and so we we have to be involved with
other people and if the only way that
you can be involved with other people is
to
serve them then that that's good
you know so you can have relationships
with people
just serve them whenever you see it
possible you don't have to be serving
them all the time but you can be finding
service
when it comes when you when when you see
it and if you're pre in
living in the present which was where
where god is is only in the present
right he's only between words he's in
the breath
i understand it at some level and i
understand it somewhat at an
intellectual level and somewhat at a
let's say an intuitive level
and sometimes i feel it but i have a
difficult time
in first of all intellectually
understanding it too so i understand it
but i don't and then i feel it but i
don't
what does it mean that god is only in
the present moment
isn't that something
only in the present time
thank you so much for doing this and
like act like you're
on you're just talking to me what does
it mean that god is in the present
moment
in order to access god you have to be
patient and wait
and you have to be
listening that's the only it's so
subtle it's so subtle
that if you're talking you're not
listening if you're
attending to other things you're not
listening you really have to be still
and you have to wait it can take a long
time
too you know i've had troubles i've had
things i'm trying to
cope with for weeks before i get an
answer
and in that time all you're doing is
waiting
for a sign i know what reborn means now
i think
what does it mean i think it means
when when when they say someone is
reborn it always sounded like what
reborn what the heck is that i think
what it is
is that you have found your place
god's here and you're here or god's
beside you he's just a little bit bigger
god's you know he's he's always just a
little bit bigger than you he's inside
you but
he's more than you are and
you're reborn you're reborn with
god before you know before it was you
self will and then afterwards it's god's
will
you're reborn with god that's reborn
that's pretty it's not
it's not hokey pokey or anything it's
pretty
yeah you know i understand that does
everyone need to be reborn
or do some people because of their
upbringing they already see themselves
as minuscule compared to god so they
don't have that
rebirth yeah that with a i think maybe
with a
a very careful spiritual
upbringing and luck
you can um you can have that
but still you know the challenges of
life will be there and
for it to be an individual relationship
with god
you're given these problems that might
be generations old
to deal with meaning
like for example oh well things that may
have happened to your grandparents
are things that are still happening to
you until you
uh recognize them in your life
and then maybe you can heal them
what would be an example of that abuse
abuse right abuse would be one thing
so if somebody and then you know your
your grandfather and then and then your
one of your parents and then
your parents behavior and that's
interesting you
you have the same behavior and then you
get married and you show the same
behavior with your
spouse and then your children learn it
from you and it just goes on and on
until someone recognizes hey you know
what
this behavior this is troublesomeness
behavior wonder where it came from
and why it's there and to accept it to
accept it as
necessary to bring you
to this understanding with your higher
power
okay that last part that's interesting
accept it as necessary can you please
expand on that so if uh
so i'm so say i'm recognizing some
way that i'm dealing with my
relationships that isn't working
and i'm recognizing that it's not
working and then i'm recognizing
i'm accepting that this is the way it's
been and that i've been
dealing with things for years this way
and that
that's the best i could do because
that's all i knew
so whatever happened in the past i can
say was there to bring me where i am
today
otherwise i wouldn't be here
right interesting interesting and then
you wouldn't be in this moment
you wouldn't be in this moment without
all of that no matter what it was
which is a very tough thing to come to
terms with sometimes because
whatever was in the past can be really
something that you
are not able to contend with but if you
see it as
necessary to bring you here and hear
you are wanting to humble yourself
to god you wouldn't have got here
without that
this to me needs as a condition
an extreme amount of well maybe you can
you would disagree but
i would say self-love because
you would have to say that i don't
regret where i am where i am is okay
but then how does one balance
that as well as wanting to change
one's moral condition or material
condition in some manner
because it's it seems paradoxical
if i say i accept it that's what i have
a hard time with
if i say i accept it to me that's like
lying on
on a pool on your back and saying that's
great where i am i love everything the
way it is
rather than wanting to change it for the
better
now i'm not saying i want to change it
for the better it could be through god
but even through that
i'm changing it which means i don't like
the way that it currently is
now you may disagree about that last
part like that you don't
like the way it currently is yeah so
great tammy please help me through this
how does one
balance self-love with wanting to
improve or
change in some manner okay well there
has to be
there has to be uh self-love there has
to be self but there has to be love for
the little boy that you were and all the
mistakes that you made there how
there has to be love for that little boy
in order for you and in order for you to
be in the present and have the
generosity that you need
to let god in because it's a generous
um invitation
you know and and you're not going to
make a generous
invitation if you're not
in a way feeling like you are
the more you can accept who you are and
who you were
and the things that happened to you the
more generous you feel the more you can
let god in
because it's not it's not an on or off
switch
you know you get a little god and then
something else happens you get a little
bit more
and some days it's a little bit less and
it depends on
how accepting you are
how aware you are how accepting you are
and then what action follows
because the action will be different
than it was if you were
guarded and if you were
empty the action you you go
how you move forward is going to be
different than if you're feeling
acceptance aware
aware of the discontent aware of the
discontent and accepting the discontent
and then what action
follows for
reconciliation is going to be
different than if you weren't accepting
and so a way to move forward into a
better place
is the is the awareness and the
acceptance
but the acceptance is the hard part
because it takes
looking back in the past and
and coming to peace with who you've
always been
and who and everybody around you and
all the interactions that you've had and
everything and being grateful
that that has brought to where you are
today that's that's hard
you're giving me a different perspective
i was recently speaking to someone named
bernardo castro
he's a philosopher and he said to me as
we were talking he said kurt don't take
yourself too seriously and then for me
i'm thinking that i don't take myself
seriously enough i see being ascetic and
austere as
something i should be and even
necessary for moving toward a higher
purpose but then i also see that
right now as i'm speaking to you
maybe that's or plenty of that is me
a distaste for what i currently am in a
dislike for my former self
and that's not easy it's not easy to
accept it's not easy to
confront no it's a process a long
process
but a constant process what else besides
god
and besides the fragility of life has
changed in your outlook
since your illness um
hmm
my
well because i made a deal with god that
i would share
with other people
if they asked me to
my community is growing
more than it ever has your community
meaning
people like a community okay you mean
like your social media
yeah people i'm in conversation with is
growing
uh for me personally more than it ever
has before
tammy what troubles me is
i want to be oriented by the truth
follow the truth wherever it takes me
and love and so when i say love i mean
that truth is not enough because
there's too much truth and you don't
know what to choose from
so then guide yourself with love and
truth okay
but then what troubles me is how do i
know that those
ideas that occur to me those spiraling
ideas
aren't a part of the truth and that i'm
supposed to follow them
see that's what makes me well write them
down and share them with people
and find out right
and don't share and i wouldn't share
them so much online i'd share them in
real life
because you know the the online presence
is kind of paranoid
or can be paranoid and and can
and grow conspiracy theories and stuff
the online
voice is too remote
so i think uh sharing your ideas with
with people that you
know is the best way to keep your head
straight
how do you choose between truth and love
in a relationship so for example
what if your partner hypothetically
committed a crime like what if i
murdered someone or whatever it may be
and
or my wife murdered someone so do i have
an obligation to the truth that is to
turn her in
or to love that is to not lie in
contradiction with my partner but
instead
with her or though somehow the same
truth and love
so what would how do you know when to
stand with your partner
and when to not
well you're not responsible for what
your partner does
they're responsible for what they do and
what they say
so you're not responsible that you can
still love them
and people are pretty confused so
they're often not telling the truth when
even when they think they are
so truth is a hard one it's you know
it's something you can aspire to that's
for sure and so is love
um because people can love for
manipulative reasons as
well you know so love isn't always true
either
but as but if you can say that your
love is true and your and your truth is
true
then i would say that uh
i would stay with love and
let the world take care of the truth
how did you know when you were young
peterson said jordan peterson said
that you said let's get married but only
if we tell each other the truth
okay how did you know that truth was
imperative when you were so
young because many people they didn't
value truth until they had this
philosophical framework given
to them by your husband and i don't know
how
without strong adherence to religion
how someone can come to a similar
understanding at such a young age of
the vital nature of truth how did you
when he asked me to marry him he said if
we have to tell the truth
if we don't tell the truth we can't have
a relationship
so that was the beginning of me walking
around with the bible in my pocket and
looking to see if i was telling the
truth
that's how i dealt with it i just put
one of those little pocket bibles in my
inside of my coat pocket and everything
i did i
analyzed to see if this was a if this
what i was doing was okay
i mean thank you so much i know you got
to go there are some audience questions
i can read them and maybe you can give a
quick answer
and if you have to go then just let's do
a few let's do this yeah salt lemon said
what are some of the best things your
dad did
or let's say your parents when you were
younger
in terms of parenting or in terms of
parenting well anyway he
uh he taught me sports he took me along
to
sports uh to games we played a lot of
games
and that was great
okay this comes from feels like fire
what advice
would you give to parents who have a
child with a condition like michaela's
let's make it more general with just a
extremely
ill child i'd put them on a meat diet
how did you okay irish lobster which is
hilarious i don't know if that's
there's a connection there how did she
know jordan was quote-unquote v1
how did he ask her to marry him what is
she passionate about
i know she does massage their therapy
but i would love to know more about her
internal world
well hopefully we gave you a glimpse of
her internal world so far but
as for the other questions that is how
did you know jordan was the one how did
he ask you to marry her what are you
passionate about
um i've known jordan for a very long
time he asked me to marry him
a few times once through a letter um
another at a party
i was just getting down on the knee i'd
say maybe maybe
is he serious that's what i was thinking
at a party publicly
not publicly my privately at a party uh
but through the latter i i thought i'm
not sure that this is
i can't i don't know if i can take this
seriously it was just
so he asked me a few times but i never
did say no
until i said yes i see i see
and then what are you passionate about
what am i about art
i'm passionate about art and my
grandkids
okay vegmek wants to know some of your
favorite books
hmm
i just read a really good short story
called
how to how to cut a knife
i think that's it let me see
it was great it was from laos
and it was how to pronounce knife that's
it how to pronounce
knife that was good that was short
stories you could read them all
separately
but the power the power of the narrative
grew
with each story to the end i thought it
was really good
so that was a good story in terms of my
favorite books
um you know the master and marguerite is
a great book
and i think that's on george list um
you know i read
i read a lot of
inspirational stuff
like self-development or yeah yeah or
religious self-development
um and you but i imagine you would do
that now you didn't do that before
i i've always i've always read
i wouldn't call it self-help but more
like
and i wouldn't call it philosophy but
you know i've always been trying to
figure things out and make things better
you do whatever whatever comes there's
something about your voice that's
kind loving tender gentle
it comes through thank you yes jordan
said that you were a tough cookie but i
don't see that i'm sure you could be
i'm sure i don't see it i mean i don't
mean that a bad way like i don't
sense any malice or any
overconfidence on your part well i think
bravery bravery
is you don't have to be bigger than an
aunt
to be brave
best ebrot says i would be interested in
what she makes of how jbp
so jordan peter you know yeah being
portrayed in hit pieces
it's must be so frustrating being the
person who knows him best
and how caring he is uh
i don't know i think it goes with the
territory that you get hit pieces
and i think that
it just it
it's news it's just clickbait news where
these
staff beats off your shoulder now in the
beginning did it bother you
no in the very beginning in the very
beginning you know in the first weeks
where there were
in the first days where there were
journalists standing on the
sidewalk in the foyer in the kitchen and
talking with them in the living room
that that was pretty overwhelming and
then
they started coming for interviews and
there were like i don't know
three or four interviews a week it was a
lot and they were in my house
and i found the uh
you know they're hungry for information
and so
it was difficult to
put my foot down and then in live events
i was told i could kind of put my foot
down i'd gone with
to one of jordan's lectures when he was
starting to get quite a
a number of people coming to his his
biblical lectures or
no this was in ottawa um
one was at the public library and one
was at the uh
national museum in ottawa okay so you
went in person
there were lots of people there and his
brother was there with me and he said
that he works with politicians
and that when this talk is over and
everybody gathers around and wants to
ask questions
that he had a method for dispersing
people so i tried his method
for dispersing people and nobody moved
do you mind saying that nobody moved
oh just walk up put my hand on his
shoulder and say five minutes you got
five minutes
nobody nobody cared luckily luckily the
library was closing
so they just laughed but that's when i
decided
i had nothing to do with that that i
wasn't that wasn't you weren't that was
not me
that was no people okay yeah
yeah did it did you feel like you lost
him to the crowd or did you
sorry what i mean is i imagine that the
amount of quality time you spend
would have been reduced it very much was
and that's why i traveled with him
largely was because i thought if he went
i had lost contact with him so much that
i thought i'd better
travel with him to keep any contact with
him at all
and it was good that i did because after
that i got so sick that that was the end
of our relationship for a long time
okay now this is the last one because
you gotta go and i just keep saying
gotta go jordan's gonna kick me out of
his office
that's fine that's fine so revulet this
person named revulet and then also
someone named echo
echoed this question same question mrs
peterson
your husband said that in a recent
interview you told them you'd get better
on your wedding anniversary and that
ended up happening
do you think it was a lucky guess or if
not
what do you credit for having been able
to predict this
i don't know what do you think it was
pretty strange
it happened on the day to the day
yeah i said i told him probably in when
i was really sick in june
that i would be better august 19th and
that's the day i was better
that's the day that they said you're
better you can leave
so i don't know i don't know what that
was tammy thank you so much
thank you it's an honor i wanted to meet
you in person and give you
i think i told you a choice cut of meat
do you still
follow your husband and daughter's diet
or
not my husband's diet my daughter's diet
now i eat lamb
no no vegetables no vitamins
just just meat a little bit of chicken
wings
oh there he is okay you gotta get going
i gotta go all right
okay thank you thank you so much i
appreciate you welcome
bye-bye have have a great rest your day
you